hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to powerwash simulator
i don't know why but i keep being drawn
back to this game
and i just have this strong ambition
to clean this skatepark completely i
don't know what it is about this game
that keeps bringing me back to it but
there's something
so incredibly satisfying about
just power washing and that's it
so my objective in this particular
episode is just to do
this particular job as meticulously
as i can and i don't know what order i'm
going to go in i don't know how i'm
going to approach it
but all i know is that i really really
want to wash
this skate park and i want to make it
perfectly clean and i want to do it
like as well as i possibly could
and uh that's going to require some
patience and some
careful approach to this so so first i'm
going to tour the park
because i know that there's a lot to do
here there's a lot of grime here there's
mud splats
graffiti it takes some work to get those
out
um but i think just watching this
skatepark just come to life is gonna be
i don't know almost
magical in a way but honestly it's not
too terrible in terms of like little
hidden crevices
it's all big flats uh big open areas so
what i'm probably gonna start with is
i'm probably gonna start on the walls
just to get those out of the way and
then work my way down
to the floor last yeah so without
further ado i'm gonna i'm gonna get
going on this
i think i'm just gonna green nozzle it
for now
[Music]
anyone ever explain to you what kind of
compound they use for structures such as
these
uh is it creosote it better not be
creosote
i really hope it's not creosote because
i've heard bad things about creosote
one about the flammability and the you
know general toxicity of it
[Music]
you know what's crazy is like um i've
recorded these in bulk just like one day
after another
sometimes multiple on one day but it's
been three days in a row that i've felt
this compulsion to play this game
and uh i don't know how it's being
received i don't know how
how people feel about washing it but i
honestly don't
care which is strange i mean i usually
don't care
like if if i like something i'm gonna
play it no matter what but just like for
this one it's just like
it's so bizarre i i legitimately am just
like
i absolutely must play this game
i've never felt that kind of a
compulsion about things
yeah but it's good oh it's good for
those that get it
like you really get it i'm assuming for
those that don't i mean i guess at this
point you've been washed out so
[Music]
i kind of feel bad washing away the
graffiti i'm not a big fan of like that
you absolutely must keep uh keep things
like this clean especially in a skate
park right
like it just becomes part of the uh i
mean it just becomes part of the park
right
can't really take that away i mean
unless it's just a horrifically
obscene uh graffiti or whatever but
like sometimes and most of the time
actually
like graffiti is art no different than
art that's in a museum except it's where
everybody
could see it which is kind of cool i
think
you know i think anyway so i'm not a big
fan of the whole idea that you have to
power wash
every piece of graffiti away then again
the paint beneath it is pretty nice i
don't know why i'm not able to strip
that away
there's something about this being safe
for that not sure how they differentiate
but there are some pretty vibrant colors
under this
you guys ever played jet set radio i
didn't play it too much because we
didn't actually own a dreamcast so
whenever whenever we played it we just
have to play it over at a friend's house
or something like that but
it was my first experience with like the
art of graffiti and like the underground
of graffiti
what not like that's pretty cool but it
must go
because apparently i've been hired by
somebody to do this all right
farewell sorry i need money
in a weird way i guess you could call
cleaning an art too
there are some people that are really
good at cleaning and organizing and
there are some people that are like
very poor at it in their day-to-day life
like me
um but there is an art to it you know
it's like a craft to it
not saying this is specifically that but
you can kind of feel it
it's it's not so much adding as it is
removing but
maybe it's just like the idea of working
in negative space
which is beautiful in a lot of ways like
uh and it's kind of like
nature just tries to reclaim things and
it can make it quote unquote ugly
but mostly just because it's nature
applied to a medium that
i don't know nature isn't used to being
applied to say concrete and whatnot
but uh yeah
i don't know what i'm talking about
[Music]
and there we go oh look at this already
look at this already
[Music]
nice
oh who's cmfd who are those who is that
person that loves themself maybe
there's history in it history and then
then again there are inappropriate
places for graffiti like
period like going out to a national park
and just like riding on rocks and like
stuff like that that's no good that's
that's no good
there's a time and a place for
everything maybe that's kind of like the
idea you know there's a time for
everything too even if the place is
appropriate for it like right now what
this skate park needs
is not so much the graffiti or like the
the history that it represents but it
needs like a fresh start
you know it's time for kind of a rebirth
of this park
and maybe i'm being too artsy fartsy
about it but just like
the idea that some things have a time
and a place
like this heart who knows if they're
still in love or if they would want to
come back but
maybe they would never want to come back
if the park never got a
renewal you know like they would never
come back here because the memory of it
would be tainted so you can't have one
without the other so you kind of gotta
you kind of gotta purge it all and give
it new space so that people can have a
new beginning here and maybe new people
can
come in here and have very special
memories that they would be compelled to
draw something like this
maybe i'm being too poetic about it i
probably am i get that way about a lot
of things
some things are more simple than others
where's the big giant dick on the ground
that i'm going to reveal after i clear
some mud off here that's what i'm
waiting for
goodbye cmfd
carl magnuson and oh well gone now
didn't even get a chance to think about
that one oh it's good i wasn't gonna be
clever anyway so
really saved me for myself
i love the sloppy sound of the mud being
washed
very goopy damn look at that i didn't
even
have to clean that graffiti off of i'll
fit there
maybe that's good maybe i don't need to
do everything so meticulously
i just want to you know
i've been watching alone i know
everybody has but just like
god something about that show just
really uh really creates a yearning in
my
soul to just go into the woods and i
know if i did that right now i would
die and i you know i would be eaten by a
bear or something or wolves would come
claim me in the middle of the night but
like my survival skills are
pretty non-existent like as much as i
would fantasize about it i'm pretty sure
that uh
i'm a city man but it makes me want to
you know
like the simplicity of it everything in
life is
unnecessarily complex at times meaning
is represented by the simplest things in
that show where um
just the pure joy that some of these
people get from just
securing their next meal like
kind of the respect that you have for it
and life in general from
life or death amounts to whether or not
you
are able to hunt something down
sometimes being connected to nature in
the universe and all that stuff
not something that i can say with any
authority
because i haven't experienced it but you
know i kind of want to
no big conclusions here but just
generally it's a good show
really helps keep things really helps
keep things uh
again in perspective can i get up here
no i cannot
[Music]
nice nice nice just all very nice it's a
band-aid or a skateboard
and i can't tell do skateboarders use
band-aids
or they just wear their wounds openly
like badasses
i'm gonna guess that
[Music]
it's a weird kind of when you're
cleaning you have to match the brush
strokes of the
graffiti artist or the spray strokes
whatever you would call those
so in a way you're kind of like copying
the art just in reverse
i don't know there's another poetic
thing to probably say about it but you
know i'm just an so
what does it even matter they'd probably
be pissed
they wouldn't see it as a sign of
respect or anything they're just like
hey
that was mine what the hell are you
doing oh is that what i think it is oh
is that what i think it is
oh is that what i think it is oh hell
yeah
oh hell yeah i still have no idea what
that means
i'm gonna leave that one i'm hoping that
the wall will be uh completely clean
without me having to remove that one in
particular
i don't know why but i want to leave
that one up and this is like some
horrible hate symbol that i'm not aware
of but then it would be incredibly
embarrassing that i'm trying to protect
that one but i don't think that's the
case so i'm gonna leave that one
[Music]
how the heck do you make a slope out of
concrete uh with
frames my dude unless this isn't a
serious question and you're just messing
with me or not frames but i don't know
the
molds whatever you would call them magic
is what i meant to say
100 magic skate magic actually they pray
to the god of skating and then
it blesses them with glorious half
pipes and beautiful curves
might as well go up here seems like the
best approach
[Music]
surprised there isn't graffiti on the
top of these somewhere seems like
something that people would do
climb up graffiti it for no one would
ever see and maybe they would assume
that someone
who is less detailed than i would clean
not too bad i'm here they must have
known i was coming
bling
[Music]
okay not too shabby
i'll just remove the dude
i guess i could have left him hanging
i'll leave half of him
[Music]
ah there he goes vanished into the ether
at what point is it gonna say this is
done
gonna be a little early on it look at
this job i'm doing
not quite imperfect most definitely
but hey isn't it all about the perfect
imperfections isn't that a thing
life and whatnot yadda yadda imperfectly
perfect
no yeah i get it i get it
i know erasing you right out of
existence
tiny bucks tim nice
and gone oh man there's a lot on here
and there's a lot on there too
um let me see if i can do close green
yeah that'll do
[Music]
another smiley face go bye-bye is that
the eight-pointed star of chaos
oh that's corn oh this is a 40k
reference
oh well i can't delete the the mark
of cornblood for the blood god indeed
but chaos undivided get out of here yes
undivided is chaos not at war and that
doesn't even make sense what is going
on here get out of here for those of you
who have no idea what i'm talking about
don't go down the rabbit hole because
you'll never come out of it or do come
down the rabbit hole talk to me about it
ask me about it
man i know so much about the 40k
universe it's not even funny but then
again i've kind of kept out of it a
little bit
or not kept out of it but i just haven't
had time to catch up with like the new
lawyer and
the new books i've been trying to read
one of the most recent books for quite a
while now and just like
haven't had time i'm gonna have to get
rid of the corn symbol aren't i
it's gonna make me do it i don't wanna i
don't wanna
i don't wanna clean up all the little
bits before i have to do that
all right fine oh sorry
sorry corn daddy
yeah there we go enjoy your corn flakes
[Music]
i'm sliding down you know it's a
staircase i'm sliding down i'm not sure
if it's this muddy what they're
suggesting doesn't seem to be quite
gelling with reality but
maybe it's just a water pressure that's
blasting me backwards and i'm just
sliding down slowly because of that
that's what i'm gonna assume
[Music]
that's looking pretty good there must be
a segment of this wall that i'm missing
otherwise like the top of somewhere
something like that
maybe on the other side oh did i leave
graffiti on the other side oh i did
oh i didn't want to get rid of this but
oh well alas oh
sorry oh it lives on forever doesn't it
there we go ah damn only five dollars
for that wall
good god they are not giving me a lot
for the the exterior but god look at
that
look at the vibrant colors ooh i missed
on that one
and how did you get this way
there we go that's what i thought now
did i do this i did the railing here i
did that there
i guess i need to do this god the grime
is really stinking up the place
i'd rather deal with grime than graffiti
though god the graffiti is
admittedly kind of annoying for moral
implications and also just like it's a
pain in the ass to clean
so i'd rather not have a lot of that and
i know i could use soap and i probably
will use soap at some point for like
some of the
the flooring just because it makes it
easier but i'd rather not use soap
that was nice that was a nice one i
don't know what made that one a nice one
specifically but that was just really
nice and satisfying the way that one
carved away
[Music]
all right now the tippy tops
let me up there let me up there
yeah there we go okie dokie okey-dokey
um
come on let me up there ah all right
fine then
okay i won't get up there now
[Music]
one thing that i think is beautiful
about the game is because i'm not
typically a super patient guy when it
comes to like
meticulous things in games like park
designers and even like the sims or
something like that
or sim city or city skylines i'm not
usually the most meticulous
placer of things because the time it
takes is
i mean sometimes it's like impossible to
maintain for the experience but
i don't know something about this just
makes me want to take my time
it it's like designed to teach you
patience i'm not sure if there's like
some rust on here or something
i'm not seeing okay there we go i guess
i'm done
oh is that the perimeter oh did i
get the perimeter
done before i even thought i was that is
the perimeter um i guess i'll get to
work on the benches and whatnot
these will be fun these will be fun oh
yeah
[Music]
let me give one more pass on this
probably do it with the green
nah
[Music]
i wish there was a way to slow it down
oh chewing gum who put gum on this thing
oh that's what's gumming up the whole
thing it looks like i got it all
looks pretty clean to me come on just
give me the credit give me the credit
i'm done here come on give me the credit
what are you doing to me
chewing gum where i don't even see it
how do you see it i don't see it
[Music]
okay apparently i got it good lord next
uh this
[Music]
the rest is gonna be a pretty easy clean
i think the walls really were the
hardest part with the most ingrown stuff
ingrown ingrained stuff these are just
basically mud
not really good for skateboard wheels i
imagine
i haven't never skated much i could
always pick it up but at this point
i already broke my foot i don't think i
need to break anymore all right what
about this
there's one thing i know about concrete
is it you're still on about that dude
get over it it's fine concrete can be
curved
the people of this town are kind of dumb
i'm starting to think hey there i got
one hell of a filthy
sidecar yeah in a minute i'm getting
this done i'll be with your car in just
a moment i want to finish this park
which weirdly enough it may not seem
like it but i am in fact almost done
[Music]
papa you
next
[Music]
just the simple pleasures in life
nothing more complicated than that
i'm not even gonna try to justify my
enjoyment of this anymore
because it is just good it is just good
and
one should not question something that
is simply good you should need no
justification for it
unless you're a truly horrible person in
your past time is murdering people
don't enjoy that don't enjoy that
i'm gonna stop making blanket sweep
statements i'm gonna put this
exclusively to just
power washing if you just enjoy power
washing
you don't need to justify it so long as
power washing objects and not the
like faces off of other humans again if
you hurt anyone with your power washing
powers then you can't enjoy
you know the flooring is so big that i
don't think i have to be super accurate
about it
however i don't want to use that as an
excuse to just like half-ass it
um but i do think that i could probably
get away with just using the white on
the majority of it just to get a
like the baseline done and then it would
eventually give me the credit for all of
it and i know that
but so long as the cleaning pattern is
good i guess is really all that matters
give it a good once over
[Music]
the time lapse is gonna look so good on
this i know that
oh it's gonna look so good
[Music]
the universe has been corrected the
wrongs have been righted
and all is good with the world
for now except for this bowl
dirty dirty bowl watermelon bolt too
[Music]
blam get out of the bowl get out of the
bowl
damn it i gotta like get some speed on
it
ah come on
yes oh come on
damn it
yeah get out of here i don't know why
that was so exciting
but it was
[Music]
sixty percent told you the rest of this
was going to flow pretty quickly
[Music]
oh i wasn't done
it's kind of funky out like i think my
technique is improving
such to the point where i can walk and
navigate my
my pressure exactly where i need it to
be most of the time
without having to worry about like oh is
that a person wait
what am i seeing here you guys see what
i'm seeing this is mega man
you see what i'm seeing now we're
getting to the good stuff the long
strides if i can stop missing patches
just following the lines that i've
carved already
get out of the way stool what are you
doing here
ruining my lines
[Music]
this might be my favorite thing
just like this long
path that i'm doing through this whole
park is
it might be the greatest thing it might
actually be the greatest thing
i'm i'm loving this i thought i enjoyed
this before but
holy crap this is great
this is great
[Music]
it just looks so good is the thing it
just looks so
good it looks so good how could anyone
let this park
fall into disarray like it just looks so
good
the colors are so vibrant it's so
beautiful
it's gorgeous it's gorge
it's so gorge does that washer work on
hedges
ah i mean if you want the leaves blasted
off i guess
[Music]
do
bam bam
bam oh wow
that's a section done i can't believe
look at this place
holy crap just look at it oh
it's freaking gorgeous oh it's so
pretty who'da thought this was lying
under here
oh my god oh my god
where's my ladder where is my la there
it is come here you time to get up on
this arch
so strange to be almost done this one in
particular has been just a delight
it's it's as if i'd never want it to end
and like i'm almost getting sad now that
i know that i'm almost done with the
skatepark just because this one has just
been such a loving craft
and there hasn't been any like secret
little cracks or anything like that
it's just all large objects so like
nothing's hidden
everything's out in the open it's very
clear what is and what is not dirty
like it's like you just got to clean it
and that's all there is to it
you just clean and then when you're done
you're done and you
you just get done what am i going to do
what am i going to do with myself
i guess i'll go clean something else
actually what i'm going to do is i'm
going to get an upgrade
i'm going to get an even better power
washer and then i'm going to get a hell
of a lot better at power washing
and then i'm just going to be slapping
things done left and right
cannot wait cannot wait
last little bit god this has gone by
pretty quick
i mean this episode obviously recording
a little longer but honestly this whole
park did not take that long and i think
it's because i i did it in a very
thoughtful way you know i was very
conscious of exactly where i was going
what i was doing at all times
i was trying to make it make pretty
logical sense
and which would have been most authentic
in the time lapse which i'm looking very
much forward to
like i cannot wait to be done with the
to watch the time lapse of it all come
together because i think the way that i
did it's going to look
particularly satisfying and it has been
a thing where it's just like i've used
the right tools for the right moments i
think
at least like i could do this with a
little farther away because the angle
kind of widens up over the end but it's
got more pressure but then you know
i can go a little faster but i am i am
going to have to come back like a few
more laps if i do this
and if i do the wider one i go a little
slower because i need to make sure it
gets it all scrubbed away but it is a
wider
thing and i don't have to be as you know
instant reaction about where i'm going
with it because i do i need to guide my
path
but i am getting better at guiding the
path walking the line
i have a bad feeling it's not going to
let me finish this so i'm going to kind
of dirty it up a bit
just because i want to like i'll leave
that as dirty
just so i can feel like i finished
something
that's probably going to give it to me
anyway don't give it to me too soon
not yet i'm not done
ah there we go looks like i've missed a
spot
what could i possibly oh that rail
oh that rail i missed you how did you
get away from me
oh there's another rail door railing
wall wall
this wall oh look at that
there we go i'm the very first wall that
i did i missed
or one of the first walls and bada bing
bada boom ooh
there she is
[Laughter]
oh not that folks seem grateful all i'm
getting so far as gas from the baggy
pants brigade complaining that they
don't look so
lick sick no more which is surely the
point yeah i don't know how they were
able to skate through what was there
before so i i don't know they don't
really have a leg to stand on in that
one
but god damn that's nice and now is time
to upgrade to the heavy duty
[Music]
[Laughter]
now what i am going to do though is i'm
going to try this out on the motorbike
which i
imagine has a bit of built-in rust but
with this new
power washer it should be no problem at
all
let's see how she does on the widest
first
oh look at the blast look at the blast
oh it's not even a problem who even
needs the other nozzles when your white
nozzle is this good
my goodness not even a challenge anymore
it's like a torrential downpour oh it's
like a
gale force winds ah
this is this is this is nothing there's
nothing to it
nothing to it does this do oh my god
legitimately just
so much power all the power
oh the power oh the power give me the
professional duty one what does the
professional duty one do
do i even want to know can one man
tolerate that much power
probably not oh no one man should have
all that power
something something that about the hour
huh baba
oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah what is this like
dude kamehameha good
god that is some
power a lot of little pieces on this but
i'm sure i'll get all of it
[Music]
boom done easy like
it was nothing like it was absolutely
nothing good
god that's gonna have to be it for now
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for enjoying this
i hope you did i had a great time take
care of yourselves take care of each
other power wash away
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you